the intimate part of our marriage is
over
she tells me nothing special happens in
our room
well that's because she's
murdered our intimacy
with betrayal
cody brown and his wife christine's
marriage has reached its breaking point
well so he gets to have an intimate
marriage with other wives but not with
me
and i'm what can i have nothing for the
rest of my life
fans will recall the couple's
relationship has been strained amid the
covet 19 pandemic which has caused
friction about where to live i really
like living separate i like my own space
i like my own autonomy i feel like i
like me better now and i just feel like
i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
how to spend the holidays we are going
to go to aspen mentions for thanksgiving
but we will be here for christmas
on sunday's episode of sister wives on
tlc christine revealed that cody no
longer wants to be intimate with her
because of her recent behavior he goes
i'm not really interested in that
anymore
i don't like your behavior
we'll see if you can be a good sister
wife and all this and i'm like okay so
you don't want us to have an intimate
marriage
and he goes no
but the tlc star says she's not
surprised about it
we went out for our anniversary we went
out for our anniversary
came home and just fell asleep and i
i've known of course i've known it's not
that i'm dumb
and he said a while ago that he wasn't
attracted to me or anything
so
i just thought that maybe it would get
better
but ultimately a non-intimate
relationship is not something christine
wants
i'm not okay with staying in a marriage
where there's no intimacy that's not a
real marriage so what does cody think
about all this
now i gotta admit this isn't totally
unexpected
because uh honestly she um
hell we've had uh serious trouble
troubles in our marriage for 12 years
she said don't i don't want you to stay
in my room anymore
just like my room is a special place to
me and nothing special happens there for
us
i'm like
okay
it turns out these intimacy issues have
been going on for a long time the reason
i wonder if this is a phase with
christine or something else
is because she's been
telling wives and adult children that
she's wanted to leave me for years she
tells me nothing special happens in our
room
well that's because she's
murdered our intimacy
with betrayal
while christine not happy with cody's
decision decides to take action of her
own
the weirdest thing just happened
i came out
to the garage why is it christine's
house
come his books
cody's books
coy's clothes
cody's clubs
guess i've been moved out of the house
yup christine moved cody's belongings
out and she seems very relieved i feel
like i can take a breath
and get myself grounded
of course this follows the news of the
two reality stars announcing the end of
their 25-year spiritual marriage last
november the aftermath was captured on
the family's reality series mary i can't
do marriage with cody anymore i don't
want him you don't get to give up like
that i don't want to do it anymore when
cody caught up with e.t months before
their split he talked about the
difficulty of making multiple marriages
work and why divorce is never an option
i'm not in a place where i i say hey to
a wife i'm leaving you that's just never
going to happen
um it's just not you know
if our relationship isn't good then we
either figure out how to work it out or
or whatever i don't even know what that
looks like we've been doing counseling
for
seven years you know
well not out of my mouth necessarily the
problem for us is this is that there's
five of us very five different thinking
adults who are trying to raise kids
together and have a family together and
we don't see eye to eye on all things we
have different values about things and
when you have that you you're in a place
where somebody one person or more can be
influenced in your life
against how you like it i'm trying to be
a husband
a father to their children and lover to
two people who may not see i die that's
a real challenge
[Music]